el nuevo coronavirus ya ha causado más
de 5 millones de muertes desde que la
oms decretó el estado de pandemia global
en marzo de 2020 entre los cerca de más
de 247 millones de casos confirmados a
nivel global un año y medio después de
las primeras restricciones sanitarias
este primero de noviembre países como
israel uruguay o tailandia le abrieron
sus fronteras internacionales
es una buena oportunidad para venir al
sur como saben hace mucho frío en europa
ahora así que decidimos venir aquí y
desaires audio en otras latitudes del
planeta un método para validar la
reapertura ha sido la imposición del
pase sanitario pero en la capital de
marruecos rabat este documento fue
objeto de protestas
el pase sanitario es una violación de la
constitución y de las leyes
internacionales estamos aquí porque al
principio nos dijeron que era opcional
pero luego descubrimos que es
obligatorio somos los primeros a los que
nos importa nuestra salud nos preocupa
más que a ellos
mientras tanto en rusia empezó este
lunes una semana de vacaciones forzadas
y pagadas para la mayoría de rusos una
política federal con el objetivo de
revertir la tendencia creciente de
nuevos contagios y de alentar la
vacunación entre una población escéptica
hasta hasta el sueño no creo que ayude
no creo que estas medidas ayuden para
nada es una semana de no trabajo pero la
gente trabaja así es
creo que sí ayudará veo que la gente no
tiene muchas ganas de vacunarse espero
que ahora vayan a recibir el fármaco
al tiempo que el mundo avanza a
distintas velocidades hacia la
recuperación los líderes de las 20
potencias mundiales acordaron en italia
de nuevo una acción multilateral para
ayudar a los países pobres a dejar atrás
la crisis sanitaria y desde este lunes
en la cob 26 se espera el debate sobre
como la prevención de nuevas pandemias
depende en gran medida de la acción
climática